[Music]
in the descendants three trailers we're
told that Hades and Umar set on wrecking
revenge on mal but is the real threat to
Oregon actually someone from within here
are five signs that Audrey is the
unfashionable dark force that Disney
synopsis warned us about
Audrey's outburst within the first few
seconds of the trailer we see King Ben
getting down on one knee and ask him out
to be his queen their beautiful moment
is ruined when Audrey yells in response
to his proposal
Audrey's outbursts shocks her grandma
Queen Leah and Chad Charming who are
standing on either side of her why is
she so against to Ben and mouse happy
news sure she once dated Ben's so it's
natural that she'd be jealous but she
didn't react in such a strong way when
bin declared his love for mal at the
tore knee field in the first movie
there's more to it than that
Audrey's fury has everything to do with
then asking mal to be his queen we know
that Audrey was totally set on becoming
Queen if this princess is all about the
titles and she's got her eye on a
promotion to the top rank
Chad made it clear that Audrey wasn't
into him because his name's Prince Chad
not King Chad so if you're looking for
Audrey's motivation it probably has
something to do with the title into the
power that comes with it the crown soon
after King Ben proposes we hear him tell
Mao that Maleficent sceptre as the
Queen's crown had been stolen the camera
cuts to a hand reaching out to take the
crown take a close look at the sleeve of
the thief and you'll soon realize too it
is that pink towel leather effect
clothing could only belong to Audrey we
then see a news reporter filling us in
on what's been happening saying a
sleeping style has spread throughout our
dime
cut to Audrey seemingly asleep on a bed
with mal and Evie around her don't be
fooled though we reckon Audrey is faking
it and it was actually her that caused
the sleeping spell it makes sense giving
her family knows a thing or two about
the subject
you simple fools it's like the Sleeping
Beauty movie has come full circle now
Aurora's daughter is using the same evil
spell that Maleficent used against her
mother and this time around
Audrey's directing it at her mother's
enemies daughter the scepter when the
reporter says they're trying to discover
which villain has perpetrated this evil
sleeping spell we're shown Hades Celia
and uma but what if it's not any of them
what if it's actually Audrey that's to
blame or perhaps Audrey's not working
alone Lucie in the lobby and then the
trailer cuts to a figure in the shadows
she's wearing a long black coat and his
holding Maleficent sceptre the bigger
thrust the scepter Ford and there's a
flash of light
we cut immediately to fairy godmother
running up steps and turning to stone
the way it's edited leads us to believe
that the two moments are linked it's
hard to make out her face but we're
pretty confident that Audrey is the
figure in the cloak holding the scepter
you only have to look at pictures of
Sarah Jeffries shooting scenes for the
movie in a forest in that outfit to put
two and two together in another trailer
we saw the back of Audrey holding the
scepter standing in front of a cottage
in the forest it kind of looks like the
cottage Aurora lived in with the fairies
in the original Sleeping Beauty animated
movie
Audrey definitely gets her hands on the
crown and sceptre we knew she was a mean
girl but we never thought she'd stoop so
low it's all about mal Audrey's got beef
with mal that much is clear to anyone we
see a moment in the trailer when mal
looks shocked bringing her hands up to
her mouth and disbelief it looks like
the back of Audrey's head is in the
foreground could Audrey be revealing her
wicked ways to mal and been perhaps
Audrey's been busy plotting her revenge
on the girl who stole her boyfriend and
her future title now is also the
daughter of Audrey's mother's mortal
enemy so it's safe to say that after
that motive in the bag that could be why
Audrey didn't appear in descendants two
but Jack got a call from Audrey just
before the cotillion asking for his help
because her car broke down and the
Sherwood Forest
surely if she were with the fairies they
could fix a broken tire with her magic
we think Audrey lured Chad to the forest
to help her with her wicked plan
was certainly in a forest with a Chad in
those pictures that show her in the
black cloak wearing the crown and
holding the scepter faceoff time it's
clear that mal is going to be the one to
have to deal with whatever evil force is
threatening our Don and we're pretty
sure that's going to be Audrey at the
end of the trailer we seen mal turn into
a dragon she only does that when she's
up against a serious enemy we saw her
transform into a dragon in his sentence
- when she battled Ouma and this time
she's facing off against an enemy on the
castle roof the camera angle is so high
that it's hard to make out exactly who
that is standing on the roof but if you
look real hard you can see what looks
like the glowny top of the step derp and
the shadowy figure holding it sure does
look like the black-cloaked audrey
dragon now breathes fire at the figure
so it's clear that it's in a name the
trailer ends with another card flashing
across the screen
this one says betrayal below a picture
of what looks like the sector we think
that's a pretty big clue that audrey has
betrayed all of Aragon by turning evil
do you think Audrey is the real threat
to our don in d3 let us know in the
comments below that's a wrap please give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to our channel for more great videos
like this thanks for watching
[Music]